Schubert was more than just a late night
host it was often our voice our refuge
and in many ways our political dad and
it's weird because that is left and now
and now it feels like the family has a
new step dad and he's black
Oh Jon Stewart has given me lots of
advice he said I should trust my
discomfort that was the main thing he
told go for the thing that makes you
feel the least comfortable I don't think
you could have handed it to a better
person it's good to see a person of
color somebody from another country come
in here and and leave the show in a new
directions I think fresh faces are good
I saw trevor no would you stand up and
is so awesome and this is the first show
looks like really like exciting
too soon
you